you ever like chat
thank you
good evening everyone and welcome to
this Northwest area planning meeting I'm
held today 8th of February
2023. my name is councilor Maddie
Thompson I'm the chairman of this
committee before we commence the
business of the meeting there are a few
housekeeping issues to run through one
is we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you're giving your
consent to being recorded when invited
to speak please turn on your microphone
and speak clearly referencing a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers keep your contributions in
clear and concise as possible and ensure
your microphones remain off when not
speaking as this is important for the
live streaming to be heard clearly
finally can I draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is the
door behind the top table
members can I draw your attention please
to the members update which has further
information on item 8 on the agenda
right so now we have um apologies for
absence Mr Jones please
thank you very much
uh right item three is the minutes um
it's recommended the minutes of the
meeting held on 11th of January found on
pages 7 to 12 are approved as a true and
accurate record may I take them as red
members thank you I so propose seconded
right does anyone have any matters of
accuracy to Rose
okay couldn't we agree those but I sent
please members excellent thank you
thank you all right Moving On Again item
four Declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registerable interests and non-register
Report interests relating to items of
business on the agenda having regard to
paragraph 9 and appendix B of the code
of conduct for members and members are
reminded they're also required to
disclose any such interests as soon as
they become aware should the need arise
through the meeting members anybody
councilor Darren
uh thank you very much chairman chairman
I do have a non-hunary interest as a
member of Essex County Council but
having consulted the monitoring officer
I have a disclosable pecuniary interest
in relation to item five on tonight's
agenda because I'm a professional civil
a funeral celebrant and although being
self-employed I do work for some local
Funeral Directors so I will be leaving
the room at the time of that agenda item
thank you thank you
anybody else somebody else okay
so we are moving on to our first actual
planning application which is land
opposites at Margaret's Church Malden
Road wood and Mortimer I think chairman
interest thank you your your moment to
move we will endeavor to remember to
retrieve you councilman Durham
um we
we do have a public speaker on this to
follow the presentation that will be Mr
Richard Evans so we'll have the
presentation first thank you um so
that's uh oh I apologize Mr Johnson
foreign
thank you chairman
that this application proposes the
erection of a crematorium with ceremony
Hall Memorial
Arboretum and Associated land use
restoration of Cooper's Monument
vehicle access parking Landscaping
pedestrian Crossing and the diversion of
a footpath yeah
so we start with the location plan
so we can see the site uh outline there
Malden Road at the top the site is to
the South and sort of extending towards
the uh South Southwest
and here we have the block plan
um in more detail
um and then it's quite small so um a bit
difficult to see but you can see the
proposed buildings and car parking down
in the southwestern area
um extensive landscaping around the site
there just to the north of that is an
existing tree line and hedging sort of a
shield in that element of the site
from significant public views looking
South
and if we extend towards these sort of
more North
Eastern part over there we can see the
secondary car parking in that sort of
horseshoe Arrangement there the access
um just uh to the again sort of
northeast of that that's the proposed
new access
at the road there we have the new
proposed right hand turn of the a414
into into the site
and over to the right of the cursor we
can see the see the Obelisk and just
south of that we can see an Avenue of of
proposed trees which which frames
um part of the public footpath which
then extends again following the
boundary sort of Southwest and down
along the side and down that edge there
and across
um
the officer's recommendation is to
approve
um subject to the conditions set out in
section eight
um
the summary of the report section 3.1
it says the application is on the
southern side of Malden Road
um
the application site is currently open
grassland
and immediately west of an existing
agricultural site so this so this so
this site is is part of a much wider
site the report sets out that in terms
of the area and its contest within the
sort of wild agricultural field it
amounts to approximately about 7.4
percent of the area itself
um
this is a fairly significant in terms of
the impact that the development would
have upon the nature of the landscape
there the quality of the landscape and
its overall impact and it's wider in its
wider context
um
we can see again just north of Malden
Road there's a number of listed
buildings
um we've got church of Saint Margaret's
wooden to my whole
Etc
um
now just in detail the crematorium
building would be a part two story part
single story building so if we just so
we've got the we've got the proposed
floor plans there
the top plan shows the
roof as I said it's a part two part
single story building to the right
um of their this sort of colored area
that's the sort of uh arrival area
um the actual if we look down at the
bottom
uh we can see the actual access if we
just take the cursor slightly up we can
see the access into the main building is
just where the just just where the
cursor is the administrative uh rooms
are to the right of the building and as
we go into the Hall uh we've got this
ceremonial rooms there and then to the
rear of that that's obviously where the
um Crematory activity takes place and
further to the right of that is
obviously the servicing area
so if we move on to the next slide we
can again to see some of the proposed
elevations
um
this is looking towards the the entrance
area which is in the
um just by the The Junction between the
two-story element and the single story
element if you just have the cursor in
that area there around yep just over to
the right sort of in that area there
um
and just over to the left right over to
the left again that's the the sort of
um sort of ceremonial access way that we
saw in the plans and on the
elevation below that's again just
looking from the other side
so again if we just move on to the next
slide again just showing various
elevations
um to the left we have the we have the
well that's where the sort of ceremonial
area is at the front there
um and the elevation to the right that's
the that's the
that's a section actually cutting
through that area those windows you can
see on the ground so they serve the
administrative rooms there and the
bottom picture that shows the rear
elevation
um to the just where the cursor is there
we can see the chimney
and again this is just the various
sections
let's move to the next one
and as uh it's headed by the slide here
we can see the cremator and gas cleaning
Arrangements but that's that's showing
the Machinery that's that's within that
um
rare sort of two-story part of the
building
again these are it's this is titled hard
Works plan but this is see where we can
see the sort of solid areas the the road
surfacing and the car parking
and that's just a detailed hard work
plan just sort of annotating the various
surfaces Etc
and there's a soft Landscaping works the
the Landscaping enhancement through
trees and planting Etc
and that's just again a key of the
detailed software plan
this slide shows the access Arrangements
um so as is set out in the report the
existing bus stop is going to be moved
from if we can just take the the cursor
over to the right of the proposed access
we can see an annotation and say an
existing bus stop to be relocated which
is currently in that area which is where
the access is arranged and it's been
moved over
um to to the to that side
that's it in a little bit more more
detail there
and this slide shows the various vehicle
access Arrangements it's a right hand
turn coming from
um
coming from the West turning into the
site
um so we can just see the see the
movements there
it's more details of vehicle access
Arrangements
and these are some photographs of the
site on the opposite side of the road
to get into small Street Scene
photographs
if we can just actually just go back to
there's a plan just going back to the to
the access Arrangements there is there
is a plan
uh right that planned there
um now sorry I've got to mention this
but this this was a matter of detail
that was raised
um the the arrangements for The
Pedestrian Crossing
which was requested if we if we can take
the cursor sort of up heading towards
the uh left of the frame along the road
yep just in that area there that's the
area of the proposed Crossing
um which again is is part of the
proposals and and has been agreed with
highways
thank you thank you for that uh so in
summary
um
the application
um has been considered against our
policies in terms of the uh landscape
and visual impacts it's considered an
acceptable impact
um there is there is no uh or in
terminology of the nppf as we say in our
reports there's less than substantial
harm
um uh to list the builders which are
quite a significant way away and the
views
um that we have here that demonstrate
the sort of distances involved and what
you potentially kennel can't see through
the through the development and in
particular the the the the middle frame
of that slide there sort of sets out the
the kind of area within which they build
in Wood
um occupy and the views and the
intervening structures and and and
natural Landscaping that are going to
mature the development from longer views
from from various areas
um
as mentioned the uh impact on listed
buildings is considered acceptable in
terms of the need the report sets out
the need
um and the criteria which the need is
established the over capacity
um of existing crematoriums particularly
in Chelmsford
um
um the uh
reports and support in this application
from
um
local crematoriums about the additional
lead
um the travel times to a crematorium in
terms of what's expected to reach a
crematorium the 30 the 30 to 30 minute
travel distance for quarters
um
these are the matters set up within the
report officers are quite satisfied
particularly given that a number of
these matters have been tested on appeal
um uh uh have in regard to the policies
in the local plan and National planning
policy
so subject to the conditions in section
eight this application is recommended
for approval thank you chairman
thank you
all right so um members we have Mr
Richard Evans pleased to come forward
um pick up any chair you like the look
of please
um make yourself comfortable please use
the microphone that's been turned on for
you we have the timer up you have two
minutes precisely and I do mean
precisely I really do chop people off
Midwood I'm very sorry it has to be the
same for everyone so whenever you're
ready thank you okay I'm the owner of
mold and Fields and I've worked in
cremator all my working life having
previously led to Westerly group I built
21 crematoria I looked after some 35 in
total but this crematorium will be
independent family run
in close liaison with local Funeral
Directors clergy and efficients we do
not make speculative applications we
spend years looking for the right site
and only in places where there was a
genuine proven need anyone who's
suffered bereavement knows that there is
an urgent and growing need in this
district for new crematorium existing
choices are remote and overly busy with
delays of three weeks and more
especially at this time of year
Chelmsford is particularly struggling
and was never designed back in 1961 to
look after 2 000 cremations a year
premature are a special case numerous
appeal decisions confirmed they have to
be built in the countryside and away
from settlements this site is a tranquil
setting a good distance from Residential
Properties but close to the population
we intend to serve
the building was at two heights will be
a single story and will sit neatly
against a backdrop of existing trees
well screened for the main road and able
to offer the Privacy which is so
important to the bereaved it's been
designed to respect the Royal character
of the area blending into surroundings
with all existing landscape features
retained with many more trees and
hedgerows planted greatly enhancing the
ecological value of the site would be a
layout amended in consideration to our
neighbors only a fraction of the site
will be built upon we've added Heritage
benefits including the restoration of
the Cooper's Monument
just four Services would be held on
average each day outside of peak traffic
but we will still provide a right-hand
turning lane and The Pedestrian Crossing
and Highway officers do agree but our
proposers are acceptable there'll also
be significant travel savings across the
area so no need to drive to Chelmsford
or Beyond we therefore hope you endorse
a strong recommendation of your officers
and vote in faith of our plans tonight
to improve the facilities sorry perfect
well done thank you thank you thank you
pretty much made it
[Applause]
um okay members um you've heard the
recommendation is to approve but I'm not
going to put that yet so um
someone care to begin a discussion and
we'll see if a proposal comes out of
that right so I have councilor white
followed by Council let me uh thank you
chairman I mean I I have to say I
suppose we've all got a um interest in
this because we're all getting older
um but um I think this is a really good
idea it's well needed
um I think we do need in the district
um wherever you put it there's going to
be some residents who don't want it but
I actually think we need this it looks a
really nice sympathetic design I really
like the design of it so I'd like to
propose that we approve the application
as a recommendation
do I have a second after that all right
okay I cancel a few seconds
um okay um who did I have next uh sorry
Council Fleming
thank you chair
um I just wanted to ask Michael can you
just clarify it's not a Crossing it's a
pedestrian island is that is that
correct
ladies and gentlemen uh that is correct
it is a pedestrian Island so they'll
cross from one side into the middle
um obviously wait for the free flow of
traffic to pass and then they will cross
over
thank you chairman okay Council offend
me thank you chair if I can just come
back
um
I like the design of the building and I
I agree there's a need uh for this in
the district
um my
I have experience of this
um my father died during covert and I
remember being told that there was a
six-week wait
for him to be cremated so we actually
and then the funeral director said well
how about there's a new crematorium
that's been built a private crematorium
why don't you try them and they were
able to fit Us in and I have to say the
whole experience was it was so well done
it was a beautiful setting so for the
residents of Malden
I think this would be I'd love them to
have this access to this service but I
am concerned about the road and the
access into the site because I drive
that road every day I drove here on that
road today it's 50 mile an hour
um so I think
a pedestrian Island I'm looking to you
Mr Johnson I know Essex highways have
said that it's all fine and and it you
know fits the specifications but I am
concerned about the speed of that road
thank you
it's defensive
thank you chairman
um I can't speak authoritatively about
Highway matters in that particular
respect
um the speed of the existing Highway was
a matter that was raised
um in the consultation process
um
my response to that as within the report
is that um
the highway Authority are not saying
like a fallback response but this is
some of the highway Authority have not
raised an issue in terms of the speed of
the traffic
um they feel like the measures in place
what's been proposed
um particularly how the
um
The Pedestrian Refuge within the road
has been designed to
as they do protect
persons crossing the road is
satisfactory for that road
the Highway Safety Orders had been
carried out they've been checked and
they're considered to be satisfactory
um so on that basis I I have no reason
to doubt the final assessment of the
highway Authority in that respect thank
you chairman
then Council more company Council Keys
all right can you imagine chairman I
know the place of sugar beet Hill but
that's for me it says here
5.2.1 now at work they call me the
professional mall I was at culture
crematorium last week in Chelmsford
crematorium the week before it says the
proposed development include a provision
for a large Car Park area
how many spaces yes I'm a great fan of
trees
and shrubs but
can we have more spicing because people
just park
everywhere there is never there is
certainly not enough space that
Chelmsford there's certainly not enough
space
at Colchester now putting in shrubs and
plants takes out valuable car parking
spaces I don't want to see the whole
thing covered in Black tarmac or
concrete but
they never seem to be looked after that
well like most industrial States and
Retail Parks the poor things sit there
gasping for water in the middle of the
summer covered in Utah I know this is
not going to be with the litter
situation but people just walk through
the hedges knock them down Park on them
parking them
is there anything we could do to make
the provision
and stipulate how many spaces we can
have
and also would there be electric
charging points in the said crematorium
for somebody that has got quite a lot of
money to afford to buy an electric car
to park now we can only look at the
application
actually it's the carpet because it's
got in here it's got synthetic material
with the pros use a rule set and
preserve the best possible slim amount
of landscaping
I'm good
can we put a condition I don't know but
I think everybody in here knows there is
not enough room to park at a crematorium
and a lovely hedge looks wonderful
but it's not practical
thank you thank you chairman um I I can
only really respond on the details in
the application
um the standard assessment for a
crematorium of this size in terms of
parking provision would be 60 spaces
um this application is proposing 84
spaces
um so there is a you know a qualitative
um
um improvement over what's the standard
assessment
um set out within two parking spaces
uh as the chair said we have to deal
with the application that's in front of
us and because there is this over
provision right probably partly because
of reasons that you've stated
um it's it's considered acceptable in
this in this particular sense
who knows about the future but if this
application were supported at this stage
um if there may be a need for more
parking spaces it can be justified and
there isn't the Palm basically you know
the arguments that have been made here
that may be for another consideration
but in terms of what's here
we're we're actually satisfied that
there is this particular over provision
over the standards that has to be
welcomed thank you chairman I cannot
come back how many seating spaces is
there
inside
do we know that I can't find it it's
been here somewhere else
it's it's it's yeah the calculations are
based on two persons this is two persons
per car based off these things no based
off the 60. that's 120 yes and and and
84 spaces are being provided
right
thank you very much
think about it chairman um
although I'm very sympathetic to this
proposal but I feel I have to sort of
represent the uh the interests of the
local Parish Council
um from with a multiple who uh echoed
councilor Fleming's concerns about the
a414 uh and the fact that this is likely
put increasing pressure on what is
already a very busy road
um and wonder whether that since this
position is primarily to relieve a
pressure on on areas such as in the
Dengue where such facilities simply
don't exist at all that's whether any
consideration was given to another site
perhaps in that particular area for this
facility to be placed
again we can only look at the
application we have in front of us if um
Mr Johnson councilor I do it I do
apologize
I do apologize it doesn't get worse than
that maybe Mr Johnson
Mr Johnson
um please feel free to comment if you'd
like um
thank you chairman uh Council Morgan I
mean there is really very little I can
say in response to that um I do
I'm aware fully of the uh Parish
council's comments and um
um you would have noted officer response
in in respect of that
um
the applicant had said
um not just here as you heard earlier
but also within their submission that
alternative
um locations had been considered
scoped out assessed in terms of
you know the appropriateness obviously
there's a whole range of methods they'd
have to consider and it is in their view
that this is this is the ideal location
this also in terms of the site
circumstances is a matter of
considerations and also things of access
while I do I take the the point about
driving along a414 I drive along it
myself so I do appreciate that but
um
this is considered to be the most
appropriate location to fit the
applicant's requirements is satisfied
for Implant in a sense but also our
consultants in terms of Highways Etc
thank you chairman thanks so much
oh sorry Council Morley yeah thank you
um you say other areas were considered I
mean it looks to me that field a bit
further
near a Danbury Direction but it's a
slight you know straighter Road you
can't see it on there to the left of the
plan there
would that not have been better with
because you sort of you've got the the
access they're on a bend and everything
I'm surprised that that's
been accepted really
where other sites I know we got to do
what's in front of us I know I know I
know I know but it just seems
crazy that's right on that bend there
thank you
please do thank you thank you chairman
um I
I I understand the point when you look
at the plan and what you can see there
does appear to be a curvature in the
road
um but this is a part of the highway
consideration there's the sight lines
um and and the uh extent of visibility
above the
um the footway and the length of views
afforded to make sight lines acceptable
in their context is one of the things
that highways consider in terms of their
highway safety and their Highway audit
there's extensive views from the access
either way up to 130 133 meters of of
clear views
um that is considered satisfactory it's
not a steep and it's it is very gentle
um I have to say I personally know that
because of the road myself and
um
you know it it more than satisfied the
appropriate views to ensure a
satisfactory Ingress and egress
sorry could you just go back and show me
exactly where the access is in relation
to the church please is it right
opposite the church
I couldn't really see from the plane
um I think up there you can see the
yeah that's that's the church
councilor femme thank you chair sorry
Michael going back to the access and and
installing that right hand turn are they
sort of planning that they will take a
bit of as you know that road you'll know
where I mean as you sort of go along the
straight bit and you you come to the
councilor Morley's right it is a bend
and on the left there's the the church
but there's a sort of
bit that you can pull off in front of
the church are they intending to sort of
make that part of the highway it's under
highways land ownership I would think
because I just knowing the road I'm just
I'm just concerned about how it all fits
in and you can see the highways boundary
there is is that going to be
incorporated into the highway
do you know
the access obviously the relocation of
the bus stop is very much a part of to
facilitate the the ease of movement to
ensure that the right hand turned also
facilitates the overtaking
um on the uh on the
West East easterly Direction
um that's about limit I can say
um the
yeah I mean the boundaries of the site
are just set within uh the plan as you
can see it there I can't comment any
further than that thank you chairman
it's outside the control of the
applicant so we couldn't do anything
about it anyway councilor sizzle
thank you madam chairman yeah if you
look on uh slide or page 16 of the
slides it actually shows that layer and
I think what they're doing from what I
can interpret uh
I think I've got a different slide
number it's page 6 16. I think it's one
before that Devin
maybe that I don't know which one it is
now
that one I think yeah it's that one with
the bus on it
um it looks like they're they're taking
Land from the left
yeah yeah so they're not encrypting on
the other side they're taking the lamp
from the left which is
yeah so
thank you
right um I'm going to put this to the
vote now I think
um I think it's about time we did
everyone's had to say so we
um have the proposal to accept the
recommendation as given in the office's
report that's proposed by councilor
white seconded by councilor Keys those
in favor please
uh those against
right so I want to cancel them all
against councilor Flemings that and
abstaining
so that is in fact passed in line with
the office of recommendation so
thank you very much everyone and we will
move on now to item six and counselors
yes councilman I get the impression
Council of Durham is listening and you
can come back now
foreign
six is the golf driving range Burnham
Road wood and mortar millets on page is
37 to 96 now this is a little unusual in
that it's a continuation of
previous
that was heard in a previous meeting in
October which means that only those
members who were present that time can
vote which reduces our number to myself
Thompson councilor Keys Council of
Durham councilor Morgan councilor Morley
and councilor white and Council Stevens
was among that number but is
unfortunately not able to be here so
um I'm sorry councilor civil Council of
Fleming you can't take part
um so the presentation is from Mrs hona
and we have Mr Tanya told Anthony
O'Toole the Urgent to speak following
that thank you
thank you chairman so this is an outline
application with all matters reserved
for up to 18 units and the pros also
includes a demolition of the existing
building on site and the removal of the
driving range and pitch and put use this
application was previously presented to
members in October but case law and the
town on Town and Country planning act
require that if any new material
considerations come about prior to the
issuing of the decision noticed then the
decision maker must have regard to this
consideration
two new appeal decisions have since been
received that are material
considerations in the determination of
this planning application and I'll try
and give a brief recap of the
application so this is the location plan
and with the site outlined in red
extending an area of 3.4 hectares
this is the indicative layout so in so
far as is relevant to the new material
consideration being presented tonight
it's relevant to note that there is a
footpath along the western boundary of
the site to conduit Lane and which
provides access to the relevant bus
stops
however as we previously presented
offices of reviews unlikely to be used
due to being unlit and involves walking
within a road which would deter users
during dark times and Times of inclement
weather
and just to recap that the bus service
is considered limited and there's also
no shelter for westbound services on the
a414 bus stop
this is just recapping on the tree
constraints plan
the relevant site history so there was
two previous applications at the site
for 25 units which
um in part refused due to the
unsustainable location of the
development another application was
dismissed for eight dwellings
at the time of the 2021 application the
council couldn't demonstrate a five-year
housing land Supply which is the same
situation as this application
and it was also previously considered
that 25 units would not offset the harm
as a result of in part the inappropriate
and unsustainable location of the site
this game proposes proposes lesser units
and therefore the benefits are
considered considered lesser
two of the 2017 layout
the 2020 layout
the 2021 layout
and then some photos of the access in
and around the site
photos looking out from the access
within the driving range itself
and the pitch jump up
so members had previously resolved to
approve the application stating that a
reason for approval that included the
site was the sustainable location it was
previously developed at land and they've
been biodiversity gain a decision has
not yet been issued on the application
as the section one and six when A6 had
not been signed until last week on the
19th and 20th of January two repeal
decisions were received one relating to
previous development land in
southminster and one to the
sustainability of wood and Mortimer as a
village for one dwelling
section 70 of the Town and Country
planning act requires a planning
authority to have regard to all material
considerations
clay law is clear that any new
information that comes in between an
area planning committee come into a
resolution and a decision notice being
issued should be fully considered it
also states that whether delegated
officer becomes aware of a new material
consideration the delegated officer must
refer the matter back to the committee
for reconsideration in light of the new
consideration if they fail to do so the
planning Authority will be in breach of
its statutory Duty
so in terms of how the appeals relate to
this application the self-minster appeal
decision confirms that the use of
previously developed land is in line
with the national planning policy
framework in respects of the wooden
Mortimer decision which relates to one
dwelling the inspector noted that the
appeal proposal would not be sustainably
located
they stated that would and Mortimer as a
village in regardless of the settlement
boundaries is one of the least
sustainable locations to deliver housing
to meet local needs in the district
the bus service was found not to provide
an attractive alternative mode of
transport
there was no shelter in the western
bound service he's on the a414 bus stop
no lighting along the a414 to access the
bus stop and no continuous safe footway
by Conduit Lane into the main village
and its facilities
the inspector found that the services of
the village were limited there was a
lack of foot ways and the nature of the
bus infrastructure
that the occupiers were the one dwelling
would have available to them
sorry so the occupies at dwelling would
be heavily reliant on the car which
would be contrary to achieving
sustainable development and a low-carbon
future
these points are applicable to this
appeal scheme and the harm is Amplified
by the fact that the application is for
18 dwellings rather than just the one
therefore there'll be a far greater
impact as a result of the use of private
cars the inspector afforded the harm
arising for the conflicts with policies
S1 and sa significant weight despite
limited out to date and the presumption
in favor of sustainable development
irrespective of how this impacts a
previous resolution officers previously
advise that they consider the site to be
unsuitably located and unsustainable and
it is believed that the appeal decisions
further supports this case law and the
town on Country planning act require
members as a decision makers in this
scenario to take this new material
consideration into account when
considering the application
there have been no new material
considerations and respects of the other
reasons for refusal presented by
officers previously and therefore no
further comment is made in respect to
those and if members are still managed
to approve the application then
conditions have been
um suggested on the updated report thank
you chairman thank you
um I'm good to ask Mr O'Toole to come
forward in a moment there's just a
couple of items of
um clarification the um
the decision notice could not be um
could not be released until the section
106 was signed is that correct yes
that's correct and the section 106 was
not held up by the local planning
Authority that is down to other matters
over which we had no control that's
correct yes thank you very much right Mr
Alto please
foreign
good evening uh this committee voted to
approve the application in October and
the section 106 has now been signed with
confidence to provide for eight
affordable housing units Finance for the
NHS public open space and a Rams
contribution now we appreciate there
have been a couple of appeal decisions
concluded during these intervening
months and understand that plan has an
obligation to bring these to your
attention
no recommendation is attached to today's
report it is purely for information
purposes only we believe that these
cases spare little relevance to the
application site before you for the
following reasons
each application needs to be assessed on
its own merits the Bryant's Lane appeal
is nowhere near the development boundary
and is separated by the a414 and Open
Fields also this was for a single
dwelling with no Community benefits
there's since stark contrast to the
application site which is surrounded to
three sides by the development boundary
provides much needed housing for the
borough and is within easy access to
transport links
crucially the planning inspector for
that appeal determined that wooden
Morton was not one of the most
sustainable villages in the borough this
does not mean that the village is
unsustainable and does not undermine the
committee's previous decision
the appeal in southminster was one which
was initially refused by the local
Authority and subsequently overturned
the key takeaway from this decision was
that redeveloping previously developed
land should be promoted
the council have acknowledged that the
application site is also considered
previously developed land
this appeal only serves to support this
application and highlight how it should
be approved fundamentally nothing has
changed since October to make this
application site any more or any less
sustainable we therefore ask the
committee to stand by their previous
determination thank you
all right members I have
oh thank you chairman chairman I I
really don't think we're going to
achieve much by redebating it because it
was debated at the huge length um in
October when we reached our decision and
I'm certainly not going to be throwing
brick backs about
um but and I think that the law has
quite clearly been followed in this case
because of the um
unfortunate delay in signing the the
section 106 and that is obviously a
complicating factor and then these two
appeal decisions came in but I think we
need to understand
the difference between the appeal site
in wood and Mortimer and this site and
what a Mortimer is it there are it's
almost two complete Villages or the
Bryant's Lane is not actually connected
with the main part of the village in
fact it's got the a414 cuts through it
and I I would say that particular part
the Branch Lane side of wood and
Mortimer that's not sustainable by any
stretch of the imagination but that
isn't the same for this side of uh for
this side of wooden Mortimer because it
has got a pedestrian access to
um to buses it has got I mean you within
less than a five minute walk you've got
a pub and restaurant
um so you can't you're not comparing
apples with apples I'm afraid um in this
and so I I do accept the
reasons why it's come back I stand by
the reasons which were very heavily
debated actually argued in October but I
stand by those I think we're back here
because of a technicality
um and I I will therefore make a
proposal that we stick with our original
reasons for approval
um and we acknowledge the fact
that um you know officers have quite
rightly bought this back to be
reconsidered but at the end of the day
the fundamental reasons why it was
approved against officers
recommendations in October still stand
thank you chairman
um councilor keys seconded and that was
the first hand to go up
um
right Council of keys to speak then I've
got Council white and councilman I've
got two things ladies gentlemen
um has there been a cost to the
applicant obviously he's had to come
here tonight as he had to re
set anything in no apart from his own
time what we have to do right
um I Heard
um Hannah she's done they wouldn't say
the bus stop had got no lighting down
the road this one I take it the new bus
stop that's going to be put in opposite
the crematorium we'll have lighting will
it which is no more than half three
quarters of a mile down the road
yes no
it's
um material consideration in this
application and it these are the closest
bus stops to the application site so
they're the ones that would be most
reasonably used
councilor Morgan
uh thank you madam chairman I mean mine
really is that um every application has
to be
um determined on its merits and
um Bryant's Lane is a tiny Lane and it
is on the opposite side of the A4 a414
and but that was for one house which
obviously has limited benefit whereas
this was an application which had is it
10 affordable housing units
um and for me the eight oh eight sorry
yeah
um but for me the benefits of the
affordable housing for the district
outweighs any harm and I think that also
that helps with the sustainability
because it's all on balance and for me
the Tilted balance is still in favor of
approval as we did the last Northwest
committee
thank you councilor Morgan
uh yeah I've been just follow up both
the councils that they're in white and
Keyser said I mean I thought this has
been disposed of in October it looked
some ghastly manifestation of the undead
its comeback to haunt us again and come
can we then please put a stake through
its heart once and for all tonight
well well we have a proposal duly
seconded sorry Mr Johnson did you want
to come down
yeah um so I just wanted to make a
comment obviously as you know Council
Dharma says we are following procedure
and and the steps is just full of
falling into place that that is
triggered this happening
um and it does give officers you know
the opportunity again to restate the
position as how the the policies and the
plan
um
um uh States particularly around
sustainability uh but also that um
where decisions and I'm not saying
there's a right or wrong in this so
please don't misinterpret it where
there's a decision that goes against or
is or runs contrary to officers
recommendation
um that is a decision that then
obviously May in itself become a
president for any other developments
yeah and these are arguments that we do
tend to make
um in terms of you know the location of
this site and it's access to access
access to facilities here but it also
May interpret how we then look at
applications that may come forward
because if we then have applications
that say particular areas are
sustainable in our in a sense we're
almost partly also Bound by our own
decisions
having regard to proximity and that sort
of thing so so these are just some of
the things that we want members to have
in their mind when the subsequent
applications have come come forward I
think it's something I've also said
before in others um as a sort of wider
context to to why we feel it's important
to just make these points to committee
and for committee to be aware of that
thank you chairman
oh councilor Durham but I think well
just before we go to the vote I I
totally understand what Mr Johnson has
said because he used the same argument
in October
but I do and and he's quite right to
have put that fact to us but I do think
that we made the a well-balanced
decision that was thoroughly
um
thoroughly uh debated and we gave our
reasons why
members didn't agree with the officer's
recommendation at the time and those
still stand
so I'm happy to vote now chairman
I'm grateful
for the um same decision to approve on
the reasons for approval
um now is the moment to raise any issues
you may have with the
um but the conditions which were
delegated to officers but they've been
brought back in this report to simplify
things and to speed things up because we
are ready to go with the decision notice
so is everybody happy happy with the
conditions thank you very much sir those
in favor of approval in line with
um everything in the officer's report
okay those against
right that is in fact approved um thank
you Mr Jones we can move on
and the next one are item seven on our
agenda is
Harmony kennels brookhouse Spa Lane
Hurley that's on pages 97 to 112. it'll
be presented by Mr Johnson and and after
that Mr Lawrence the applicant
thank you chairman
this application proposes a single story
dwelling and cart Lodge replace an
existing out buildings so we just run
through the slides
um we can see the location plan and the
site there you can see where it says
harmony kennels uh that little area sort
of sort of carved out there uh those
rectangular
um uh lines you can see those are the
outbuildings of which people see some
photographs later
um
and here is the proposed site layout we
can see the building
um laid out
um
sort of
well not quite centrally but almost
centrally within the within the sort of
rectangular area there you can see the
outlines of the the outbuilders which
are to be removed and obviously access
um over to the West
and if you just run through just run
through the various plans the floor plan
roof plan
um we can see the single story building
there the cartilage racing
um
pretty standard uh sort of sort of
design
and again various other elevations
and there's just some photographs of the
of the outbuildings
okay just providing some context
[Music]
um
thank you I think if we just go back to
the video yeah just um to keep on the
screen there's the overall site plan
yeah we can just just sort of have that
um
this application
um follows on from a previous
application uh which was refused
um by The Authority
um and subsequently dismissed
um on appeal these are sets out within
section three of your report there
[Music]
um
we can see that 3.14 subsequent appeal
for the previous application uh was
dismissed for the following reasons the
appeal site would not be suitable for
the development proposed it would
therefore fail to comply with various
policies we've taken together
established a strategic growth
requirements and settlement hierarchy
for the district yeah
due to the scale and overall bulk of the
proposed building um concluded that the
proposal would harm the character and
appearance of the surrounding
environment uh contrary to policies
um
one of the fundamental reasons there is
the unsustainable location of the
development which is a continuous theme
from the applic from officer's refusal
and the inspectors
um uh subsequent dismissal of the appeal
in that respect although
um the Apple the application has
responded to the elements of size and
scale by reducing the overall footprint
and and heightened dimension of the
building the issues of its
sustainability Still Remains
um
um a number of the other reasons for
refusals have been addressed
particularly in terms of the section 106
um payment through Rams and also ecology
matters so those matters have fallen
away they have been addressed by by this
by this by this application
um
but if we just go to the conclusion
um at 3.2.1 despite reduction in the
scale and bulk of dwelling the proposed
development was still result in the
domestication of the of the countryside
to the detriment of the character and
appearance of the area
uh in addition it is considered the site
is in an unsustainable location outside
of a defined settlement boundary
therefore the proposal this country to
polish this one uh eight uh H4 and D1 of
the plan thank you chairman thank you
okay Mr Lawrence please come forward
pick any chair you like
somebody next to you will help you with
a microphone
um
as you've heard me say it's two minutes
precisely from when you begin so make
sure you're comfortable and we'll start
the clock when you start
uh good evening Madam Madam chairman
good evening members our site is without
doubt sustainable with Village shop
school nursery church and Pub all
reachable using the football from the
top of spa Lane into the center of the
village
Spa Lane is a no through road with only
four properties and very little traffic
the bus stops and foot paths are only
130 meters from the site a regular bus
service to Morgan southminster Bravo in
The Villages between is available with
stops at the top of spa Lane with 18
Services daily
molden is only around three miles away
by car free Central Journeys and the
property will have a charging point to
facilitate the use in electric vehicle
plus electric air source heating the
national policy framework National
planning policy framework clearly states
there should be presumption in favor of
development on sustainable previously
developed Brownfield sites outside the
settlement boundary more so if the LPA
does not have a five-year land Supply
MDC only has a three-year Supply the
site is clearly in this category there
will be no additional visual impact as
the proposed sits on the footprint of
the ugly old kennel block it replaces is
only 700 millimeter higher and will be
built in materials traditional to the
area and former in keeping with the
removal of the other derelict kennels
visual impact will be further reduced
albeit the site is hardly visible as
there are well-managed tool Hedges and
trees on the boundaries MDC no
challenges they have a shortage of one
and two bedroom Bungalows every single
one built is helps a situation I've
always lived in the country and would
hate to live in a Suburban or Urban
environment I was born in pearly went to
school in Purley want to die in pearly
and be buried in the church I've been my
mother and father my mother and brother
sorry I have ongoing medical issues
which will only get worse I'm now
registered disabled with a change of
Need for this Bungalow I'm sorry I don't
have to stop you there understand well
done
foreign
sorry councilor Morley was that your
poor going up or oh okay right in that
case I've got counselor white Council I
mean
um thank you madam chairman I mean I
actually have got the appeal up
um and the house that was refused was
absolutely massive it was
7.38 meters high and this is four point
something meters high it was a massive
house before
um this looks much more suitable but
going through the appeal um reason eight
um it was talking about sustainability
and um it says according as a
consequence of this relationship
um and that was between the approved
dwellings
um and the visual
um and physical relationship they said
it was too bulky
um and he said and the inspector says he
does notice its proximity to facilities
and bus service under reason nine
um and
um it goes under you know three large
albeit low-rise buildings with a
utilitarian appearance
um and it says that it goes on to say
the existing buildings are not prominent
within the public realm and their scale
and appearance generally ensure the
buildings have a discrete presence
um as a consequence in my judgment the
existing buildings are unassuming and
subservient to existing established
development as well as the open
Countryside and it says it goes on 1.2
or sorry 12 The Proposal would seek to
replace the buildings with a large
dwelling the replacement building would
be two stories in height with a pitched
roof above
um although the footprint would be more
contained in the buildings it would
replace it would be generous footprint
blah blah blah blah but it says the bulk
Master building would create a large and
imposing structure that would be
distinctly at odds with the unassuming
presence of the existing buildings it
goes on to say about you know the height
and the bulk and the height and the bulk
and the scale and the bulk
um and it's because the scale and bulk
under 14 that they doesn't that he
doesn't think a cause of policies S1 S8
D1 and H4 which taken together
um sustainable development which
respects enhances the character and
local context well I think for me
um if we get the pictures up of what's
proposed and I don't know if you've got
the drawings of what was refused you
have the drawings there it was huge
um and it seems to me that the appeal
yeah and honestly it was massive but the
um the appeal was quite clear that the
reason he didn't find it sustainable or
all the other reasons was because the
building was so high and in fact on this
site
um we had two there's two other houses
that got planning permission s appeal
and I actually voted against them they
came to Northwest committee because I
didn't like the access because it was on
the bend just past the pub I didn't like
the access at all I didn't think it was
safe but the planning inspector said
otherwise and for me the fact that he's
done everything the planning inspector
said he should
um I proposed that we approve this
um recommendation I don't know if I'll
give a second off of that but that's my
thoughts on it
okay thank you okay
so
okay and reason hang on I've got to go
back to the uh um for me the reasons are
um because of the reduced um bulk size
mass and design following uh in in
comparison to the appeal site but
because of this um it does a call with
policies S1 S8 D1 and H4 because taken
together they seek amongst other things
sustainable develop much respects
enhances the character and local context
and I think that with the change in a
design that it does do all of those
things so I think for those reasons we
can approve this application
okay those are the reasons um thank you
councilor Keys
um I've sorry lost the plot ever so
slightly sorry councilman I think it was
councilor Fleming next but I will
promise Faithfully I will come to you in
councilor Fleming thank you chair
um
I just yeah I mean this road it used to
be rural but it's not anymore though
it's actually there's a it's in the 30
mile an hour limit so with respect I
actually
um I you know I I think it is a
sustainable location it's just it's
changed that road in the last
15 20 years it's a sort of long sort of
ribbon development and you can at spa
Lane you walk up there there is actually
a bus stop there and there's a footpath
relatively unusual features in the
countryside you know if there's a shop
in Purley there's there's a primary
school there's a pub there's a village
hall there's so I I I'm afraid I
disagree with the officer's
recommendation
um also Michael can I just ask you talk
about the two
um this was previously refused on appeal
different different design different
size then you talk about the two other
dwellings that which are in the uh
applicants ownership what was the sort
of chronology of that was it which one
was first if you can answer that
the two were first and then this one
yes yes that's crazy okay thank you
Council Morgan
hey I think about it John uh Debbie can
we look at the site photos
and go on to the end
keep going down right
um I'm just interested in reasons for
refusal
um it says the proposed job would have
enhance the character and appearance of
the rural area and the built form would
have an urbanizing effect an unwelcoming
visual intrusion into the undeveloped
Countryside well I mean frankly we've
got that already and we I mean I I I
failed to see that that's a valid reason
for seeking to refuse this Madam
chairman and so I would support uh
councilor white in the proposal that we
approve this application thank you yes
Mr Johnson actually wants to come in but
I'm going to say we've all seen sites
that have been allowed to get more and
more untidy and wrecked and hideous and
then we are presented with clearing that
up as a reason for a new dwelling and I
appreciate that moment but let's be
honest I hear what you're saying but um
probably asbestos there I think as well
Mr Johnson but thank you chairman that's
very much that's very much the point I
was going to make yeah you know um I
mean yeah I mean that's clearly no no
justification
um that is a site that has become
unkempt over the passage of time
um it's still a site which is clearly in
a state of flux at some point in the
future it will not remain like that even
if it's not developed in the way that's
proposed here
um so really it's just the sort of the
officer's counter to the argument that
that's actually put forward I mean once
the built form is on that site it then
becomes a permanent feature
um it would be a residential site and it
would more than not likely be there in
perpetuity so that's the point there in
terms of the domestication of the site
Etc and the domestication of the site in
the rural area
um
should not be and I'm not saying you are
counselor you know confused with a land
which has left to become
um untidy and Visually unattractive
thank you chairman
thanks okay
well please do but normally everyone
feels the need to have a go and far be
it from me to restrict debate but there
is actually no need for everyone to
agree with everyone else however
councilor siddle go for it thank you
madam
um
if I can understand everything the
officer is saying and I can understand
everything in terms of
uh the fact that this is a rural
location however it I if it was the next
field where there was nothing on it and
it this is at the end of Spotlight I
used to have friends who lived on
Spotlight just over on the other side of
it so because of what's there already I
think we've already urbanized this
particular part of the countryside I
know these buildings are dilapidated
however they are buildings they look
like someone could have lived them in
them at one point
um so on this particular
occasion I am going to agree with my
fellow members
councilor Morley and also as we are all
getting older we do need
Bungalows and things like that so I
think it's a great idea thank you
no I don't think you meant that
right we do have a proposal
we have a proposal to overturn to
approve in the name of Council of white
seconded by Council cases I recall
um Mr Jones did you get those reasons
for approval right condition oh yes
thank you uh conditions we need to
delegate to the officers I think but
yeah yeah usually unless you've got
something you want to add then oh yeah I
can't think of a reason why the standard
ones wouldn't so that's the
conditions delegated so okay those in
favor of
approval thank you those against
um I'm sustaining okay thank you right
moving on
uh
no no formal counselor Morris I don't
have all the spotty shirt especially
foreign
councilor Darren has returned complete
with his pen right we're moving on to
item eight which is not planning
application it is to confirm or not the
tree preservation order at Milhouse
Malden Road Langford
um
so there's there's no public speakers
because well hey there's no one here but
B is not a planning application so it
doesn't apply we have a presentation by
Mrs herner and uh
there we go
I think
this report relates to a confirmation of
a tree preservation order for six black
order trees and one weeping willow
located to the rear of Mill House Malden
Road in Langford
the weeping willow is located within the
circled outline slated T1 and the black
order trees are in the dashed
um Circle label G1 here and here
this is an aerial view with a red light
outline showing the location of the
trees
foreign
plan with the trees highlighted
this is a photo of the trees which
highlights the weeping willow from
Witham Road
and the photos of the older trees from
within witton Road
photos of the from within Mill House car
park showing the trees from this
location
and a photo from St Charles Church car
park
the council received an application
under reference
2200982 TCA to fill these trees and to
replace them with six black order trees
and one weeping willow in September of
however due to the replacement trees not
being enforceable under the terms of
section 211 of the tunnel crunch
planning Act and the trees have an
amenity value the council's tree
consultant objected to the works for
this reason
a Tempo assessment was carried out and
it was scored 18 out of 25 which
um is a score that says definitely State
definitely warrants a tree preservation
order so true preservation order was
then served on the 24th of October
with an objection letter later being
received in relation to the TPO the
objection relates to
the fact that
um the council stated that the TPO
served on the basis they cannot secure a
placement which the um objective
believes isn't a reason for serving a
TPO as the trees fell the condition and
amenity test they also state that there
is an intent to replace the trees and
this should be taken on trust and not by
the inappropriate use of serving an
order
the question of whether or not to
confirm the CPO has been brought before
members however it's the officer's
recommendation based on the tempo which
recognized the immunity of the trees for
their size and location and based on the
threat to the trees that the TPO should
be confirmed the the tempo guidance
acknowledges a reason for serving a TPO
can be precautionary only
however the threat to the tree goes
beyond this as the tempo was triggered
due to the quest to fill the trees and
as such a threat was imminent the tempo
score was 18 which as I've said Falls
within the definitely Merit a tpo's
category
thank you
members councilor white thank you
um well I do know that the um
the tempo system can be manipulated and
I know that because we had trees that
the author of the tempo system said did
not marry a merit a TPO but Malden
District Council saw otherwise so the
person who actually devised the system
came to a different uh decision to
Modern District Council
um now they say they're doing damage to
the house and that is a reason for
something to score a really low Tempo
score
um have we seen the report of the damage
to the house that they're causing so
obviously they can cause a lot of heave
so do we know if there is damage because
I think we need to be sure of this and
if we don't have the information on
damage but the applicant is saying there
is I'd be mindful to defer it until we
actually see if there is damage and then
I think that for me would affect today's
decision as to whether the tree should
stay or go or should have a TPO or not
because I'm not sure there's enough
information present unless I just
haven't seen the homeowner or the
building owners report
Mr Johnson is that one for you I would
have thought it said put forward and an
objection that would be the time to put
forward some evidence
damage
um councilor Keys Let's uh let's listen
to you while we have a look thank you
chairman
um
I'm involved in a tree preservation
order what was that got lifted
this has got structural damage to the
house and the insurance company done DNA
testing on the roots
and said that it was due to the Tree
Malden Council said they couldn't fight
the insurance company so they lifted the
TPO on an English Oak
now has this any of this been submitted
similar to what councilor white said
about structural damage
if we had anything and perhaps it we
should say it but they dnaed The Roots
now they've done that I have no idea but
molding Council said no got lift the TPO
because the tree's got to go down
luckily for the tree it's still there at
present but that's out of my hands now
but the TPO was lifted by molden Council
and it never even come to committee they
just lifted it
right we're talking about this case and
evidence of damage to the building and
nothing anything
um I'm not the case Office of the
application but I have just looked at
the um TC application that was submitted
which has triggered the TPO and I can't
see anything was submitted as part of
that the reasoning within that report
um is why the filling of the trees was
required is because they were leaning 30
to 90 degrees to the north
and um the black order trees are in a
spindly and in poor condition mainly
caused by swamping from a collection of
layland eye trees which just caused them
to grow towards the sunlight
not that I can say but I'd hate to say
definitively it's not the case
Mr Johnson has a page
[Music]
thank you sir I mean really just
underline that point there
7.11 of the report it says one letter of
from Sharon Hall's good Associates was
received on behalf of the owner
objecting to the servant of the TPO
um
where you know I'm familiar with Sharon
Hall's good you know submits our boy
cultural reports you know an established
um our very culturalist uh company
um and
um the objection makes no reference to
impact on
dwellings
thanks of structural damage comes
forward they can apply down the street
exactly and I think the point that um
Mrs herner was making was that it it it
secures a replacement
um you know I mean I do appreciate the
applicant talking about Goodwill but um
you know when we're talking about
um you know land use issues natural
environment we can't just go on Goodwill
um it has to be enshrined within
decisions and policies and legislations
Etc to secure the you know the the
future natural environment and Immunity
of the area
could we just have the site plan up
again just to show us the location of
the okay right well actually that aerial
photograph was quite good it was good
yeah yeah
uh look there's there's no way that the
route the roots from those trees are
going to be
um encroaching on the
Foundation okay they may suck a bit of
moisture out but
I think you know what are we trying to
achieve what we're trying to achieve by
this TPO is to ensure that trees that
are removed are replaced pretty much is
that that's it really because I think
there was a photograph and I took and
one that was sent to members of a tree
that was
at that sort of angle and that that's
going to
fall sooner or later that there's not
hasn't got a great deal of
life left in it
um and could we have a look at the the
other photograph that showed us the
trees it right okay oh no but yeah that
one there
uh
so the taller trees are the olders that
are referred to is that right
and that is in the summer by the look of
it
a night spring they don't look terribly
great do they
I don't know it's difficult to see from
here
but um
yeah they look a bit better there do we
know if the layland eye have been
removed
because they are that they are the yeah
scourge of the this was a recent site
visit undertaken by the case officer so
they're the trees that we're in
position at that time when you say re
sorry
um if that's recent so they are then
they've got to be leylander because
they're still green I'm guessing
holder Is Here Yeah
if I might come in that's not now
because the deciduous trees have got
leaves on they haven't got any leaves on
now there's no way that's now
any look okay so the really what what we
are saying it correct me if I'm wrong
chairman is that
we want to ensure that
the any trees that are removed are
replaced rather than leaving it as a
matter of Goodwill is that correct Mr
Johnson
thank you chairman that is that is
correct in one point but I I I sort of
said that there is actually two reasons
because the trees in terms of their
amenity value of themselves irrespective
of the replacement
um were scored highly on the tempo as
Miss as Miss herna says so there's so
there's two reasons
um for that but also secondly if they
should be removed for reasons that may
well happen
um then that there would be replacement
and they're in a conservation area
can we go back to the to the aerial
photograph game so I just want to try
and get my bearings
right so you've got the church so there
uh and the field at the back
on Witham Road okay
which is a private Garden isn't it out
at the back
at the top of that
photographs
it's Ted what yeah it was tense here
yeah
it's okay
there's Brick House up there yeah okay
um thank you chairman of
God
okay thank you
yeah thank you very much just as an
aside I once asked a garden expert how
close to a building
it's safe to put onto weeping willow and
he got the reply 20 miles so I would I
would say just where it is isn't
necessarily a sort of certain that's not
going to cause trouble
um I was just wondering the letter from
Sharon hosgood unless I've missed
something was that actually sent to
members beforehand
did you not feel it worth sort of
circulating it to members as part of the
part of the papers or not yeah no the
applicant it wasn't part
well I mean yes
but I just it's just going through it I
noticed that all the trees according to
the absolute are of a Tempo score that
don't necessarily don't Merit actually
having a TPO
and so I just wonder exactly why it is
we're seeking serpenters sadly we don't
have the case officer or indeed a tree
officer here too
so chairman so the only expert evidence
we've got is what we were provided to by
the objector in in the report that was
discussed correct
well and
that tree officer in the office of
report okay yeah
all right that's not part of the report
can we stick can we share that
yeah yes it informs the report um does
have a copy of
see
District council's Tempo report but it
informs the officer report so just just
as a massive process when when these
temples are carried out they are very
much intrinsic to how we consider these
reports we do see the report we do see
the the process at the at the consultant
goes through to actually achieve that
obviously they're The Specialist and
that's what we but that's what we rely
on thank you chairman
councilor siddle
I would like to propose that we support
the officer's recommendation okay
second second second about Council
Fleming says proposed that we confirm
the TPO as in line with the office of
recommendation that was councilor siddle
the seconded by councilor Fleming
can we turn that to the vote those in
favor
one two three four five six seven those
against
Council of white against the rest in
favor
um okay so that concludes that
application
um item nine is any other items of
business the chairman of the committee
decides are Urgent and you'll be
delighted to hear there are none so with
thanks to officers and members and
members of the public I close the
meeting at 8 52. thank you everyone